Trainer: Guten Morgen, allerseits! Willkommen zu unserem Schulungstermin für die Support-Mitarbeiter der ACME AG. Ich hoffe, ihr seid alle gut in den Tag gestartet.
[Gemurmel im Hintergrund, Stühle werden gerückt]
Trainer: Bevor wir anfangen, hat jemand noch Fragen oder Anmerkungen? Nein? Gut, dann legen wir los.
Trainer: Heute geht es um den Umgang mit Kundenanfragen zu unseren neuen, umweltfreundlichen Türgriffabdeckungen. Wie ihr wisst, haben wir kürzlich unser Sortiment erweitert, und das bringt natürlich auch neue Herausforderungen für den Support mit sich.
Lisa: Entschuldigung, dass ich zu spät bin. Der Verkehr war heute morgen eine Katastrophe.
Trainer: Kein Problem, Lisa. Setz dich einfach. Wir haben gerade erst angefangen.
Trainer: Also, wo war ich? Ach ja, die neuen Türgriffabdeckungen. Zunächst einmal, kann mir jemand sagen, was das Besondere an diesen neuen Produkten ist?
Max: Sie sind aus recycelten Materialien hergestellt, oder?
Trainer: Genau, Max. Aber da ist noch mehr. Wer kann mir weitere Eigenschaften nennen?
Sarah: Ich glaube, sie haben auch antibakterielle Eigenschaften. Und sie sind in verschiedenen Farben erhältlich, die der Kunde selbst wählen kann.
Trainer: Sehr gut, Sarah! Genau diese Punkte sind es, die unsere neuen Produkte so besonders machen. Und genau darüber werden wir heute sprechen.
Trainer: Lasst uns mit den recycelten Materialien anfangen. Wie würdet ihr einem Kunden erklären, warum wir uns für diese Materialien entschieden haben?
Thomas: Na ja, weil es gut für die Umwelt ist, oder? Weniger Plastik und so.
Trainer: Das stimmt, Thomas. Aber wir müssen das etwas detaillierter kommunizieren. Unsere Kunden wollen oft genaue Informationen.
Lisa: Könnten wir vielleicht sagen, dass wir dadurch den CO2-Fußabdruck reduzieren? Ich habe gehört, dass das bei vielen Kunden gut ankommt.
Trainer: Sehr gut, Lisa! Genau solche Informationen sind wichtig. Lasst uns das mal zusammen ausarbeiten.
Trainer: Wenn ein Kunde fragt, warum wir recycelte Materialien verwenden, könnten wir etwa so antworten: "Unsere neuen Türgriffabdeckungen bestehen zu 80% aus recyceltem Plastik. Dadurch reduzieren wir nicht nur den Verbrauch von Neukunststoffen, sondern auch unseren CO2-Fußabdruck um etwa 60% im Vergleich zu herkömmlichen Produkten."
Max: Wow, das klingt wirklich gut. Aber woher wissen wir, dass es wirklich 60% sind?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Max. Diese Zahl stammt aus einer Studie, die unsere Forschungs- und Entwicklungsabteilung durchgeführt hat. Es ist wichtig, dass wir solche Aussagen immer mit Fakten belegen können.
Sarah: Und was ist, wenn ein Kunde fragt, ob die recycelten Materialien genauso haltbar sind wie die herkömmlichen?
Trainer: Ah, das ist eine häufige Frage. Hier ist es wichtig, dass wir ehrlich und transparent kommunizieren. Unsere Tests haben gezeigt, dass die Haltbarkeit praktisch identisch ist. In manchen Fällen sind die recycelten Materialien sogar etwas robuster.
Thomas: Aber was ist, wenn ein Kunde trotzdem skeptisch ist? Ich hatte letztens einen, der meinte, recycelte Sachen seien immer schlechter.
Trainer: Das ist eine schwierige Situation, Thomas. In solchen Fällen ist es wichtig, geduldig zu bleiben und dem Kunden unsere Qualitätstests zu erklären. Wir könnten auch anbieten, ihm Muster zum Testen zu schicken.
Lisa: Apropos Muster, haben wir welche hier? Es wäre gut, wenn wir die mal anfassen und genau anschauen könnten.
Trainer: Gute Idee, Lisa! Ich habe tatsächlich einige Muster mitgebracht. Lasst sie uns mal herumgeben.
[Geräusche von Gegenständen, die weitergereicht werden]
Trainer: Während ihr euch die Muster anschaut, lasst uns über die antibakteriellen Eigenschaften sprechen. Wer kann mir sagen, wie diese funktionieren?
Sarah: Ich glaube, da sind irgendwelche Stoffe drin, die Bakterien abtöten. Aber ich weiß nicht genau, wie das funktioniert.
Trainer: Gut, Sarah. Du bist auf der richtigen Spur. Tatsächlich haben wir in das Material Silberionen eingearbeitet. Diese Ionen stören den Stoffwechsel der Bakterien und verhindern so ihre Vermehrung.
Max: Ist das nicht gefährlich für Menschen oder Haustiere?
Trainer: Eine sehr wichtige Frage, Max! Nein, die verwendete Menge an Silberionen ist für Menschen und Tiere völlig unbedenklich. Sie wirkt nur auf mikroskopischer Ebene gegen Bakterien.
Thomas: Und wie lange hält dieser Effekt an? Muss man die Griffe irgendwann austauschen?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Thomas. Der antibakterielle Effekt hält für die gesamte Lebensdauer des Produkts an. Wir garantieren eine Wirksamkeit von mindestens 10 Jahren bei normaler Nutzung.
Lisa: Das klingt ja toll! Aber was ist mit Reinigung? Muss man da etwas Besonderes beachten?
Trainer: Auch eine wichtige Frage, Lisa. Die Reinigung ist tatsächlich einfacher als bei herkömmlichen Türgriffen. Ein feuchtes Tuch reicht in den meisten Fällen aus. Man sollte keine aggressiven Reinigungsmittel verwenden, da diese die antibakterielle Beschichtung beschädigen könnten.
Sarah: Und was ist, wenn ein Kunde nach der Umweltverträglichkeit der Silberionen fragt? Ich meine, wenn die Bakterien abtöten, klingt das ja nicht gerade umweltfreundlich.
Trainer: Sehr gut aufgepasst, Sarah! Das ist in der Tat ein sensibler Punkt. Die verwendeten Silberionen sind in so geringer Konzentration vorhanden, dass sie keine negativen Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt haben. Zudem sind sie fest im Material gebunden und werden nicht ausgewaschen.
Max: Aber was ist, wenn das Produkt irgendwann entsorgt wird? Landet das Silber dann nicht doch in der Umwelt?
Trainer: Noch eine ausgezeichnete Frage, Max! Wir haben auch daran gedacht. Unsere Produkte sind so konzipiert, dass sie vollständig recycelt werden können. Das Silber wird dabei zurückgewonnen und kann wiederverwendet werden.
Thomas: Das klingt ja alles super. Aber ich wette, die Kunden werden nach dem Preis fragen. Sind diese neuen Griffe nicht viel teurer?
Trainer: Du hast Recht, Thomas. Der Preis ist oft ein wichtiger Punkt für die Kunden. Unsere neuen Türgriffabdeckungen sind tatsächlich etwas teurer als die herkömmlichen Modelle. Aber wir müssen den Kunden den Mehrwert vermitteln.
Lisa: Und wie machen wir das am besten?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Lisa. Wir sollten den Kunden erklären, dass sie mit diesen Griffen langfristig Geld sparen. Sie halten länger, müssen seltener gereinigt werden und tragen zur Reduzierung von Krankheitsübertragungen bei, was besonders in öffentlichen Gebäuden oder Büros von Vorteil ist.
Sarah: Das macht Sinn. Aber was ist, wenn ein Kunde sagt, dass ihm Umweltschutz egal ist und er einfach nur den günstigsten Griff will?
Trainer: Das kann natürlich vorkommen, Sarah. In solchen Fällen ist es wichtig, respektvoll zu bleiben und trotzdem die Vorteile unserer Produkte zu betonen. Wir können zum Beispiel auf die Langlebigkeit und die geringeren Reinigungskosten hinweisen.
Max: Und was ist mit den verschiedenen Farben, die Sarah vorhin erwähnt hat? Wie funktioniert das genau?
Trainer: Ah ja, die Farbauswahl. Das ist tatsächlich eines unserer Alleinstellungsmerkmale. Kunden können aus einer Palette von 20 verschiedenen Farben wählen, die alle aus natürlichen Pigmenten hergestellt werden.
Thomas: 20 Farben? Das klingt nach einer Menge Lagerbestand. Wie lange müssen Kunden auf ihre bestellten Griffe warten?
Trainer: Gute Überlegung, Thomas. Tatsächlich produzieren wir die farbigen Abdeckungen erst nach der Bestellung. Das nennt sich "On-Demand-Produktion". Die Lieferzeit beträgt in der Regel 5-7 Werktage.
Lisa: Und was ist, wenn ein Kunde eine Farbe möchte, die nicht im Standardsortiment ist?
Trainer: Auch daran haben wir gedacht, Lisa. Für Großkunden oder besondere Projekte bieten wir einen Sonderanfertigungsservice an. Dabei können Kunden ihre ganz individuelle Farbe wählen. Das kostet natürlich etwas mehr und hat eine längere Lieferzeit.
Sarah: Das klingt ja toll! Aber wie erklären wir den Kunden am besten, welche Farbe zu ihnen passt? Ich meine, am Telefon ist das ja schwierig.
Trainer: Sehr guter Punkt, Sarah. Dafür haben wir einen Online-Konfigurator entwickelt. Kunden können dort virtuelle Modelle ihrer Türen hochladen und verschiedene Farben ausprobieren. Wir können ihnen den Link zu diesem Tool während des Gesprächs per E-Mail zusenden.
Max: Und was ist, wenn ein Kunde mit der gewählten Farbe doch nicht zufrieden ist? Können wir die umtauschen?
Trainer: Ja, wir bieten tatsächlich eine 30-Tage-Zufriedenheitsgarantie an. Wenn ein Kunde mit der Farbe nicht zufrieden ist, kann er die Abdeckungen innerhalb von 30 Tagen zurücksenden und eine andere Farbe wählen. Allerdings müssen die Produkte unbenutzt und in der Originalverpackung sein.
Thomas: Das klingt ja alles super, aber ist das nicht ein ziemlicher Aufwand für uns? Ich meine, all diese Optionen und Möglichkeiten...
Trainer: Du hast Recht, Thomas. Es ist definitiv komplexer als unser bisheriges Angebot. Aber genau das macht uns auch einzigartig auf dem Markt. Wir bieten nicht einfach nur Türgriffabdeckungen an, sondern ein individuelles Erlebnis.
Lisa: Apropos individuell, was ist mit Firmenkunden? Können die ihre Logos auf die Griffe drucken lassen?
Trainer: Ausgezeichnete Frage, Lisa! Ja, wir bieten tatsächlich auch eine Möglichkeit zur Personalisierung an. Firmenkunden können ihre Logos oder andere Designs auf die Abdeckungen drucken lassen. Das ist besonders beliebt bei Hotels oder großen Bürokomplexen.
Sarah: Oh, das klingt interessant. Aber wie funktioniert das mit dem Druck? Beeinträchtigt das nicht die antibakteriellen Eigenschaften?
Trainer: Gute Überlegung, Sarah. Wir verwenden ein spezielles Druckverfahren, das die antibakterielle Beschichtung nicht beeinträchtigt. Der Druck wird sozusagen in die oberste Schicht des Materials integriert.
Max: Und was ist mit der Haltbarkeit des Drucks? Nutzt der sich nicht mit der Zeit ab?
Trainer: Noch eine gute Frage, Max. Der Druck ist äußerst langlebig. Wir garantieren, dass er bei normaler Nutzung mindestens 5 Jahre hält. In den meisten Fällen hält er sogar deutlich länger.
Thomas: Das klingt alles sehr technisch. Wie sollen wir uns das alles merken?
Trainer: Keine Sorge, Thomas. Ihr müsst nicht jedes technische Detail auswendig kennen. Wir werden euch allen nach dieser Schulung ein ausführliches Handbuch zur Verfügung stellen, in dem ihr alles nachlesen könnt.
Lisa: Oh, super! Gibt es das Handbuch auch digital? Das wäre praktisch, wenn man schnell etwas nachschauen will.
Trainer: Ja, Lisa. Das Handbuch gibt es sowohl in gedruckter Form als auch als durchsuchbares PDF. Außerdem arbeiten wir gerade an einer internen App, die alle Informationen enthält und ständig aktualisiert wird.
Sarah: Eine App klingt cool! Wann wird die fertig sein?
Trainer: Die App befindet sich noch in der Entwicklung. Wir hoffen, sie in etwa zwei Monaten einführen zu können. Bis dahin müsst ihr euch noch mit dem PDF behelfen.
Max: Apropos digital, wie sieht es eigentlich mit Online-Bestellungen aus? Können Kunden die neuen Griffe direkt über unsere Website bestellen?
Trainer: Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall möglich. Wir haben unseren Online-Shop entsprechend angepasst. Kunden können dort alle Optionen durchgehen und ihre individuellen Griffe zusammenstellen.
Thomas: Und was ist, wenn sie dabei Hilfe brauchen? Gibt es eine Art Online-Chat oder so?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Thomas. Ja, wir haben einen Live-Chat auf unserer Website implementiert. Während der Geschäftszeiten ist immer jemand verfügbar, um Fragen zu beantworten. Außerhalb der Geschäftszeiten können Kunden eine Nachricht hinterlassen, die am nächsten Werktag beantwortet wird.
Lisa: Wer betreut denn diesen Live-Chat? Sind wir das?
Trainer: Momentan wird der Chat von unserem Online-Team betreut. Aber es ist geplant, dass in Zukunft auch einige von euch dafür geschult werden. Das gibt euch die Möglichkeit, eure Expertise auch online einzubringen.
Sarah: Oh, das klingt interessant. Aber bedeutet das nicht, dass wir dann weniger Telefonanrufe bekommen werden?
Trainer: Das ist eine verständliche Sorge, Sarah. Aber unsere Erfahrung zeigt, dass viele Kunden nach wie vor den persönlichen Kontakt am Telefon bevorzugen, besonders bei komplexeren Anfragen. Der Chat ist eher für schnelle, einfache Fragen gedacht.
Max: Apropos komplexe Anfragen, was machen wir, wenn ein Kunde etwas fragt, worauf wir keine Antwort wissen?
Trainer: Das ist eine sehr wichtige Frage, Max. In solchen Fällen ist es völlig in Ordnung zuzugeben, dass man die Antwort nicht weiß. Sagt dem Kunden, dass ihr die Information recherchieren und zurückrufen werdet. Notiert euch die Frage und leitet sie an euren Teamleiter weiter.
Thomas: Und wie schnell sollten wir zurückrufen?
Trainer: Wir streben an, alle offenen Fragen innerhalb von 24 Stunden zu beantworten. Wenn es länger dauert, solltet ihr den Kunden darüber informieren und ihm einen neuen Zeitrahmen geben.
Lisa: Das macht Sinn. Aber was ist, wenn ein Kunde wirklich unzufrieden ist? Ich hatte letztens einen, der richtig wütend war.
Trainer: Ah, der Umgang mit unzufriedenen Kunden ist in der Tat eine Herausforderung. Lasst uns das mal durchspielen. Lisa, kannst du uns die Situation beschreiben?
Lisa: Also, der Kunde war sauer, weil seine Lieferung verspätet war. Er schrie am Telefon und drohte, nie wieder bei uns zu bestellen.
Trainer: Okay, das ist definitiv eine schwierige Situation. In solchen Fällen ist es wichtig, ruhig zu bleiben und dem Kunden aktiv zuzuhören. Lasst ihn ausreden und zeigt Verständnis für seinen Ärger.
Sarah: Aber was sagt man dann? Ich meine, man kann ja nicht einfach sagen "Tut mir leid" und fertig, oder?
Trainer: Richtig, Sarah. Eine aufrichtige Entschuldigung ist wichtig, aber es sollte nicht dabei bleiben. Erklärt dem Kunden, was schiefgelaufen ist und was ihr unternehmt, um das Problem zu lösen.
Max: Und wenn es unser Fehler war? Bieten wir dann eine Entschädigung an?
Trainer: Ja, wenn der Fehler eindeutig bei uns lag, können wir eine Entschädigung anbieten. Das könnte ein Rabatt auf die nächste Bestellung sein oder ein kostenloses Zusatzprodukt. Aber sprecht das immer mit eurem Teamleiter ab.
Thomas: Und was ist, wenn der Kunde trotzdem nicht zufrieden ist?
Trainer: In solchen Fällen könnt ihr anbieten, das Gespräch an einen Vorgesetzten weiterzuleiten. Manchmal hilft es schon, wenn der Kunde das Gefühl hat, dass sein Anliegen ernstgenommen wird.
Lisa: Das klingt alles sehr herausfordernd. Gibt es irgendwelche Tricks, wie man in solchen Situationen ruhig bleibt?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Lisa. Eine Technik, die viele hilfreich finden, ist tiefes Atmen. Nehmt euch einen Moment Zeit, um tief durchzuatmen, bevor ihr antwortet. Außerdem kann es helfen, sich bewusst zu machen, dass der Ärger des Kunden nicht persönlich gegen euch gerichtet ist.
Sarah: Und was ist, wenn wir selbst mal einen schlechten Tag haben? Ich meine, wir sind ja auch nur Menschen.
Trainer: Das stimmt, Sarah. Wir alle haben mal schlechte Tage. Wenn ihr merkt, dass ihr nicht in der Lage seid, freundlich und professionell zu bleiben, ist es völlig in Ordnung, eine kurze Pause zu machen. Sprecht mit eurem Teamleiter, wenn ihr das Gefühl habt, eine Auszeit zu brauchen.
Max: Das ist gut zu wissen. Aber zurück zu den neuen Produkten - gibt es irgendwelche häufigen Probleme oder Beschwerden, auf die wir uns einstellen sollten?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Max. Bisher haben wir hauptsächlich positive Rückmeldungen erhalten. Ein paar Kunden hatten Fragen zur Reinigung, aber das haben wir ja schon besprochen. Ansonsten gab es vereinzelt Kommentare zur Lieferzeit, da die individuelle Fertigung eben etwas länger dauert.
Thomas: Und wie gehen wir damit um, wenn jemand sich über die Lieferzeit beschwert?
Trainer: In solchen Fällen ist es wichtig, transparent zu sein. Erklärt dem Kunden, dass die längere Lieferzeit damit zusammenhängt, dass jedes Produkt individuell gefertigt wird. Betont die Vorteile dieser personalisierten Produktion, wie die Farbauswahl und die hohe Qualität.
Lisa: Und was ist, wenn jemand seine Bestellung ändern möchte, nachdem sie schon in Produktion gegangen ist?
Trainer: Das ist eine knifflige Situation, Lisa. Grundsätzlich versuchen wir, solchen Wünschen nachzukommen, solange die Produktion noch nicht zu weit fortgeschritten ist. Allerdings kann das zu zusätzlichen Kosten und Verzögerungen führen. In solchen Fällen müsst ihr das klar kommunizieren.
Sarah: Und wenn die Produktion schon zu weit ist? Müssen wir dann "Nein" sagen?
Trainer: Wenn die Änderung nicht mehr möglich ist, müsst ihr das dem Kunden freundlich, aber bestimmt mitteilen. Erklärt die Gründe und bietet wenn möglich Alternativen an. Zum Beispiel könnte der Kunde eine zusätzliche Bestellung mit der gewünschten Änderung aufgeben.
Max: Das klingt alles sehr komplex. Wie sollen wir uns das alles merken?
Trainer: Keine Sorge, Max. Wie gesagt, ihr bekommt alle Informationen in eurem Handbuch. Außerdem werden wir in den nächsten Wochen weitere Schulungen zu spezifischen Themen anbieten. Es ist ein Lernprozess für uns alle.
Thomas: Apropos Lernen, gibt es irgendwelche Quoten oder Ziele, die wir erreichen müssen? Ich meine, wie viele dieser neuen Produkte sollen wir pro Tag verkaufen?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Thomas. Im Moment haben wir keine festen Verkaufsquoten für die neuen Produkte festgelegt. Wir wollen zunächst sehen, wie sie vom Markt angenommen werden. Allerdings werden wir die Verkaufszahlen natürlich genau beobachten.
Lisa: Und was ist mit Kundenfeedback? Sollen wir das irgendwie erfassen?
Trainer: Genau, Lisa. Wir haben tatsächlich ein neues Feedbacksystem eingeführt. Nach jedem Kundenkontakt werdet ihr gebeten, eine kurze Zusammenfassung des Gesprächs und eventuelle Kundenbewertungen einzugeben.
Sarah: Oh, ist das nicht ziemlich zeitaufwendig?
Trainer: Es mag am Anfang etwas Zeit in Anspruch nehmen, Sarah, aber es wird mit der Übung schneller gehen. Außerdem hilft es uns, die Qualität unseres Service kontinuierlich zu verbessern.
Max: Und was passiert mit diesem Feedback? Ich meine, liest das überhaupt jemand?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Max. Ja, das Feedback wird tatsächlich sehr genau analysiert. Unser Produktentwicklungsteam nutzt es, um Verbesserungen vorzunehmen, und das Managementteam verwendet es, um unseren Kundenservice zu optimieren.
Thomas: Apropos Management, bekommen wir irgendeine Art von Anerkennung für gutes Feedback?
Trainer: Das ist eine interessante Frage, Thomas. Zurzeit haben wir kein formelles Belohnungssystem dafür, aber es ist definitiv eine Überlegung wert. Ich werde das mit dem Management besprechen.
Lisa: Okay, zurück zu den Produkten. Gibt es irgendwelche besonderen Verkaufsargumente, die wir nutzen sollten?
Trainer: Absolut, Lisa. Die Hauptverkaufsargumente sind die Personalisierungsmöglichkeiten, die antibakterielle Beschichtung und die Langlebigkeit des Produkts. Betont auch die Umweltfreundlichkeit, da unsere Produkte recycelbar sind.
Sarah: Und was ist mit dem Preis? Sind wir da wettbewerbsfähig?
Trainer: Guter Punkt, Sarah. Unsere Preise liegen etwas über dem Durchschnitt, aber das rechtfertigen wir durch die hohe Qualität und die Personalisierungsmöglichkeiten. Es ist wichtig, den Mehrwert zu betonen.
Max: Verstehe. Aber was, wenn ein Kunde sagt, dass er woanders billiger kaufen kann?
Trainer: In solchen Fällen, Max, ist es wichtig, nicht in einen Preiskrieg einzusteigen. Stattdessen solltet ihr den Wert unseres Produkts hervorheben. Erklärt die Vorteile wie die antibakterielle Beschichtung, die Personalisierung und die Langlebigkeit.
Thomas: Und wenn der Kunde trotzdem nicht überzeugt ist?
Trainer: Dann ist das okay, Thomas. Nicht jeder Kunde wird unser Produkt kaufen, und das ist in Ordnung. Bleibt freundlich und professionell. Manchmal kommen solche Kunden später zurück, wenn sie die Qualität günstigerer Alternativen erlebt haben.
Lisa: Das macht Sinn. Gibt es eigentlich Mengenrabatte für größere Bestellungen?
Trainer: Ja, wir haben tatsächlich ein Rabattsystem für Großbestellungen. Ab 100 Stück gibt es 5% Rabatt, ab 500 Stück 10% und ab 1000 Stück 15%. Aber sprecht größere Rabatte immer mit eurem Teamleiter ab.
Sarah: Und was ist mit Sonderanfertigungen? Ich hatte neulich einen Kunden, der fragte, ob wir auch Griffe für runde Türen machen können.
Trainer: Gute Frage, Sarah. Grundsätzlich sind wir offen für Sonderanfertigungen, aber das muss von Fall zu Fall entschieden werden. Bei solchen Anfragen notiert euch alle Details und leitet sie an die Produktentwicklung weiter.
Max: Apropos Weiterleiten, wie sieht es eigentlich mit internen Kommunikationswegen aus? An wen wenden wir uns bei welchen Problemen?
Trainer: Das ist eine wichtige Frage, Max. Wir haben tatsächlich ein neues internes Kommunikationssystem eingeführt. Bei technischen Problemen wendet ihr euch an die IT-Abteilung, bei Produktfragen an die Entwicklungsabteilung und bei Kundenbeschwerden an euren Teamleiter.
Thomas: Und wie erreichen wir diese Abteilungen am besten?
Trainer: Wir haben ein Ticketsystem eingerichtet. Ihr könnt Anfragen direkt über unser internes Portal erstellen. Jede Abteilung hat dort einen eigenen Bereich. Bei dringenden Fällen könnt ihr natürlich auch direkt anrufen.
Lisa: Oh, noch ein neues System? Das klingt kompliziert.
Trainer: Keine Sorge, Lisa. Es mag am Anfang etwas überwältigend erscheinen, aber es wird euch die Arbeit auf lange Sicht erleichtern. Wir werden nächste Woche eine separate Schulung zum Ticketsystem durchführen.
Sarah: Apropos Schulungen, wie oft werden wir in Zukunft geschult? Ich meine, es gibt ja anscheinend ständig Neuerungen.
Trainer: Guter Punkt, Sarah. Wir planen, vierteljährliche Auffrischungsschulungen durchzuführen. Zusätzlich wird es bei größeren Änderungen oder neuen Produkteinführungen spezielle Schulungen geben.
Max: Und was ist mit persönlicher Entwicklung? Gibt es Möglichkeiten, sich weiterzubilden oder aufzusteigen?
Trainer: Absolut, Max. Wir fördern die Weiterentwicklung unserer Mitarbeiter. Es gibt verschiedene interne Fortbildungsprogramme, und für besonders engagierte Mitarbeiter besteht die Möglichkeit, in andere Abteilungen zu wechseln oder Führungspositionen anzustreben.
Thomas: Das klingt gut. Aber zurück zu den Produkten - gibt es irgendwelche Pläne für zukünftige Erweiterungen der Produktlinie?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Thomas. Ja, wir arbeiten ständig an Innovationen. Aktuell erforschen wir die Möglichkeit, smarte Türgriffe mit eingebauten Sensoren anzubieten. Aber das ist noch in der Entwicklungsphase.
Lisa: Smarte Türgriffe? Das klingt interessant. Was genau sollen die können?
Trainer: Die Idee ist, dass diese Griffe beispielsweise die Raumtemperatur oder Luftfeuchtigkeit messen können. Für Bürogebäude oder Smart Homes könnte das sehr interessant sein. Aber wie gesagt, das ist noch Zukunftsmusik.
Sarah: Wow, das klingt ja fast wie Science-Fiction. Aber was ist mit unseren aktuellen Produkten? Gibt es da irgendwelche bekannten Probleme oder Schwachstellen, auf die wir achten sollten?
Trainer: Eine sehr gute Frage, Sarah. Bisher haben wir keine größeren Probleme festgestellt. Es gab vereinzelt Berichte über Verfärbungen bei direkter, starker Sonneneinstrahlung, aber das betrifft weniger als 1% der Fälle.
Max: Und wie gehen wir damit um, wenn ein Kunde so ein Problem hat?
Trainer: In solchen Fällen bieten wir einen kostenlosen Ersatz an. Es ist wichtig, dass wir kulant sind und schnell reagieren, um die Kundenzufriedenheit zu erhalten.
Thomas: Das ist gut zu wissen. Gibt es sonst noch etwas Wichtiges, das wir wissen sollten?
Trainer: Tatsächlich ja, Thomas. Wir werden nächsten Monat eine Kundenzufriedenheitsumfrage durchführen. Es wäre gut, wenn ihr die Kunden darauf vorbereiten und sie ermutigen könntet, daran teilzunehmen.
Lisa: Okay, und was genau sollen wir den Kunden darüber sagen?
Trainer: Erklärt ihnen, dass ihre Meinung für uns sehr wichtig ist und wir ihre Rückmeldungen nutzen, um unsere Produkte und unseren Service zu verbessern. Die Umfrage wird per E-Mail verschickt und sollte nicht länger als 5 Minuten dauern.
Sarah: Alles klar. Gibt es irgendwelche Anreize für die Teilnahme?
Trainer: Ja, unter allen Teilnehmern verlosen wir 10 Sets unserer Premium-Türgriffabdeckungen. Das könnt ihr den Kunden als zusätzlichen Anreiz mitteilen.
Max: Das klingt gut. Ich denke, das wird die Teilnahmebereitschaft erhöhen.
Trainer: Genau, Max. Jede Rückmeldung ist für uns wertvoll. Okay, gibt es noch weitere Fragen zu den Produkten oder zu euren Aufgaben?
Thomas: Ich glaube, wir haben schon eine Menge besprochen. Aber eine Sache noch: Wie sieht es mit Teambuilding-Aktivitäten aus? Ich meine, wir arbeiten ja viel am Telefon, da wäre es schön, die Kollegen auch mal persönlich besser kennenzulernen.
Trainer: Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt, Thomas. Tatsächlich planen wir, vierteljährliche Teamevents einzuführen. Das können Ausflüge, gemeinsame Workshops oder auch einfach ein gemütliches Beisammensein sein. Wir sind offen für eure Vorschläge.
Lisa: Oh, das klingt super! Ich hätte da schon ein paar Ideen...
Trainer: Das freut mich zu hören, Lisa. Warum sammelst du nicht alle Ideen und schickst sie mir per E-Mail? Wir können sie dann in der nächsten Teambesprechung diskutieren.
Sarah: Apropos Teambesprechung, wie oft finden die statt?
Trainer: Wir haben wöchentliche Teambesprechungen, Sarah. Sie finden jeden Montag um 9 Uhr statt. Dort besprechen wir die Ziele für die Woche, eventuelle Probleme und teilen Erfolgsgeschichten.
Max: Und was ist, wenn man mal nicht teilnehmen kann?
Trainer: Gute Frage, Max. Wenn ihr mal nicht teilnehmen könnt, informiert bitte euren Teamleiter im Voraus. Es wird immer ein Protokoll erstellt, das ihr nachlesen könnt. Bei wichtigen Ankündigungen werdet ihr separat informiert.
Thomas: Das klingt fair. Ich denke, wir haben jetzt wirklich alles abgedeckt, oder?
Trainer: Ich denke auch, dass wir die wichtigsten Punkte